[Música]
conheci um jovem quem há cerca de 20
anos é fui chamado em sua maioria pela
ovelha tem um historial de um consumo
tilico bastante acentuada
examinei mas foi além de pernas inchadas
encontrei pouco mais é decidir fazer uma
ecografia cardíaca e para mim o grande
fato doentinho conversão praticamente
imóvel
tá legal declínio da sua fusão e como um
mal nunca vem só
numa das cavidades tinha também uma
massa de sangue um coágulo sabia estar
perante um doente muito grave onde
fiquei mameri cal na manhã seguinte
dirigiu à enfermaria prover infelizmente
já não se encontrava à via fácil o nosso
súbita cardíaca durante a noite 20 anos
uma vida toda jogada fora recente -
publiquei um artigo chamado a atenção
sobre uma causa pouco freqüente de
doença cardíaca no adulto e este artigo
remete nos para uma situação é que por
vezes o começar bem com defeito de
fabrico e esse defeito de fabrico nós
dominamos de cardiopatia estruturas que
por si só não leva a essência cardíaca
mas podem combinar como tal nos salários
meses diariamente mas sem muitos meninos
e muitos de luz nasce com cardiopatia
estrutural
algumas delas são coisas simples
comunicação interatrial mais das vezes
publicações interventivo lados mas
conversão coisas mais complexas como a
exposição de grandes artérias
e assim foi que logo no início do das
minhas funções em janeiro
o chamado a enfermaria da maternidade a
ver com ramsey na sensível 24 horas após
o seu nascimento tinha uma coloração
azul onde fiquei me a examiná lo mas
para além dos pequenos sopro e
significativo não encontrei mais nada
foi realizada então o ecocardiograma e
documentários apenas uma comunicação
interatrial uma coisa simples mas não
satisfeita com o diagnóstico que pela
colocação da criança sabia que era algo
muito grave
voltamos a fazer o exame e decidir
entrar em contato com os colegas por
telemedicina foi feita e dá o
diagnóstico de uma transposição de
grandes artérias ea criança precisava de
uma cirurgia urgente e enquanto
aguardava se usava também fazer uma
medicação mas nós não construímos essa
medicação
começou então o drama a criança
precisava de uma cirurgia urgente não
pode ser feita santo né
quem é que ser evacuada mas não podia
ser evacuado enquanto não chegasse uma
confirmação de uma vaga no hospital em
portugal a 14 meses entre o desespero de
uma mãe que dizia noturna
só vou ajudar o meu filho e eu sentindo
e completamente inútil pegando a
situação não podia fazer nada
passaram se quatro leste entretanto
chegou a ver dita confirmação da grave
agem
mas dois dias senti antes de poder
partir para viagem a bomba falhou ea
criança faleceu
estou drama que vivo gostar de letras
são burocracias que custam vidas humanas
e que é difícil ultrapassar é muito
difícil
entretanto nem tudo são coisas mais
é por vezes acontecem coisas boas
é importante estar focado fazer muito
bem o interrogatório a nossa história
clínica
chegar a um diagnóstico ea antiga em
conseqüência e assim foi que eu conheci
o meu último do euro 88 anos em a queixa
de falta vara em chassi nas pernas uma
clínica típica em seja cardíaca e enfim
é um historial de hipertensão arterial
severa e pouco americana então é
começamos por mudar o estilo de vida
praticar algum exercício
a mudança na dieta e passados três meses
e com a medicação acertava houve
melhoria dos sintomas e também da função
cardíaca doença e sentia se muito melhor
e assim é que o coração é uma bomba
orgânica revigorante é apaixonante é
capaz de polícia cada cinco acertos e
instituições por cada ciclo uma máquina
é uma obra-prima quase perfeita mas esta
bomba foi ver se falha ea questão é por
que falha
falemos de hipertensão é um assassino
silencioso outrora era ativa como doença
do país envolvido de pessoas afortunadas
mas agora tem um naco valência crochês
em áfrica estão dados do internamento
hospitalar disse lersch vocês podem ver
e 2014 e 2015 do crescimento que foi
entretanto estes dados
obtivemos existe um programa de doenças
não transmissíveis nas suas crônicas não
transmissíveis são também estes são os
dados reais que acontecem no nosso país
em 2012 a 2015 isso é a quantidade de
pessoas que foram identificadas e há
muitas que ficam de folga e isso é
assustador
então essa é a hipertensão afeta pessoas
ainda em idade produtiva a maior parte
dessas pessoas estão à volta de 40 anos
podem fazer muito ainda pelo país podem
fazer muito pela sua fifa famílias e
pela economia então leva à morte precoce
e tem um efeito negativo
a economia entretanto esta falha de
bomba é causado por essa hipertensão
uma outra situação que afeta o nosso
país é o consumo e clico bastar para ser
doado em são tomé e príncipe o consumo
elétrico tem sido uma prevalência
crescente fulminada eo álcool por si só
é um veneno por células cardíacas leva à
morte dos meus itu causa degeneração
cardíaca e o álcool está relacionado com
a perfeição com a diabetes está
relacionado com muitas vezes também com
impotência sexual
e olha que 120 temer nisso é a linha
vert méritos é uma doença crônica que
afeta muitas pessoas não é é uma doença
que afeta microvascular ação e
cardiovascular é da cabo das culinárias
e esta doença coronária até cogitou
erótica leva muitas vezes mas nem e ser
bela causa uma síndrome coronária aguda
são apenas problemas que nos aparecem
com infartos textos mas a diabetes e
silenciosa
na maioria das situações essa doença
aparece de forma sutil
então temos que estar preparados para
isso e os dados mostram anos e que
entretanto é temos muitos diabéticos e
só falava de diabéticos que nós temos
diabéticos do tipo 2 são aqueles que é
do que a de quem já tem uma idade um
pouco mais avançada e tem muito a ver
com nosso estilo de vida esses dados
mostram nos que já existem muitos
doentes nesse bom e essa diabetes então
dá cabo também da função cardíaca que
pode levar a um falha de bomba
entretanto uma temos que ver que o
desgaste cardíaco está relacionado com
fatores de risco cardiovasculares ea
sejam modificáveis e não modificáveis os
fatores de risco modificáveis vimos a
hipertensão havia vetos a dislipidemia
é termos a obesidade e também temos os
hábitos tabágicos quanto aos fatores de
riscos não modificáveis a idade a carga
genética e o sexo
então nós temos que mudar aquilo que é
possível mudar e então temos que começar
pela prática de exercício físico fui com
ele pra não dizer viária e também mudar
os nossos hábitos alimentícios
vejamos os santomenses gostam de comer
uma comida bem com limitava e achar
comida com continental vá tem um alto
teor de sol que é um é elemento
essencial para a hipertensão e uma
comida tão boa não pode ser acompanhada
pela água
então é isso tal vinho cerca de um litro
de água pra não dizer por refeição mas
também olha estamos num país quente o
calor aperta mais cerveja vem mesmo a
calhar e costuma se dizer que a nissan
que o mec a bebida quente faz bem ao
homem dá um escala existente o ótimo
eis tudo isso nós não podemos avaliar a
nossa tensão arterial medir a tensão
demais cria vícios e também não podemos
tomar a medicação medicamento demais
fazem moda homem
isto é o que hoje no meu dia a dia e
enquanto isto isto se passa é de repente
a tensão arterial aumenta aparece o avc
muitas vezes fulminante e leva à mostra
e levar o desgaste cardíaco e isso tem
um efeito negativo também na nossa vida
na nossa sociedade na nossa economia
outra doença que em pleno século 21
ainda afeta a nossa população em
constituir um problema de saúde pública
é a doença cardíaca reumática é uma
doença que é causada pela série
reumática pode ser tóxica e afeta
chegaram inicialmente as válvulas estão
mas tudo é do coração e
é mais comum adquirida na idade de
crianças e adolescentes
esta doença relacionada com a pobreza
leva à morte e pode culminar com uma
extensa cardíaca
fuly nada infelizmente eles não tomei
fisco ainda não está fora deste
paradigma
uma vez instalado o falho de bomba
aparece a display e que a falta vai os
top-16 aparece a disney pagou física
noturno na que é uma falta durante a
noite
então causa a minha ligação do sono e
descanso noturno aparece hoje saci na
perna
vamos ver mas às vezes nem chassi é
confiar na zaga em doentes de emissão da
li leste também diminui a sua capacidade
de trabalho é um cansaço acentuava
aparecem infecções respiratórias que
muitas vezes agravam insuficiência
cardíaca e vice versa e começa todo um
ciclo vicioso
então o doente tem internamente
recorrências torna-se cada vez mais
dependente pela diminuição da capacidade
de trabalho deixa de contribuir para com
a sua família não é e muitas vezes
também é um estado depressivo
o que não pode pode ajudar não contribui
esse também é um desgaste para o sistema
nacional de saúde que temos que isso
abarcar esse doente no hospital
nos internamentos recorrências e não
estaria já final desta doença aparece o
cansaço mesmo muito acentuado o que leva
a uma falta rasteira no lance e pode
combinar com a cássia e por fim com a
morta
tudo isso agrava se quando temos a
ausência de políticas que ajudem a estes
doentes quando com essa situação de
crônicas que não têm já lugar mas que
possam que nos permitam o permitam estes
doentes compararem ea serem medicamentos
de forma mais barata e que possa também
contribuir para ver - em treinamento
e que assim aumenta os gastos de saúde
que temos indiretamente
portanto os dados da mortalidade
quanto se gasta fotos mostraram que a
modalidade tem crescido investido
bastante no sentido da imperfeição
muitos jovens
acho que morrer tem a ver se pessoas de
40 anos completamente limitadas essa é a
realidade que nós vivemos agora e foi
assustador
cada um de nós destaca tem que ter essa
consciência
por isso devo dizer divulgação de um
órgão importante e temos que cuidar dele
agora imaginem que eu vos fiz essa
existem cerca de 200 bombas na estação
200 elas estão prontas a explodir
olha mas não entrei em pânico porque a
roupa do que vos falo é apenas o rosto
coração e se vocês cuidarem nem de longe
de ser pesado durar por muito tempo
obrigada
[Música]